anche oggi come nelle settimane
precedenti
parleremo di vr spero di appassionarvi
alla stessa maniera ma non inteso come
valentino rossi no no come virtual
reality
il mio primo vediamo se parte ok il mio
primo approccio con la realtà virtuale
non nasce nell'ultimo tempo ma con un
giochino trovato a casa di mio nonno era
un visore degli anni sessanta molto
semplice con delle schede che con un
click
scorrevano delle immagini era un
prototipo ovviamente degli anni 60
però era un tentativo di ambientare una
scena secondo approccio con la realtà
virtuale è stato all'inizio di
quest'anno con locus un visore
nettamente superiore a quello di mio
nonno
il primo approccio quindi è stato non
solo tecnico ma anche diciamo provenendo
anche da studi scientifici in cui anche
la filosofia e l'italiano hanno la loro
importanza è stata quella di vedere le
due parole vicine un pochettino che un
ossimoro realtà virtuale e quindi mi
sono chiesto che cos'è virtuale e tu
cosa irreale la frase che più vedo
vicina al mio modo di pensare
dal punto di vista ingegneristico è
quella che si ritrova nel film matrix è
reale e ciò che viene interpretato dal
nostro cervello
i segnali elettrici che vengono
interpretati del nostro cervello e se la
vogliamo vedere dal punto di vista
pragmatico e così quindi se volessimo
creare una ambientazione virtuale però
da farla sembrare reale serve
coinvolgere tutti i sensi farla sembrare
appunto reale cosa significa poi dal
punto di vista pragmatico sicuramente
coinvolgere tutti i sensi quello visivo
senza dubbio la realtà virtuale infatti
ha un elevato esasperato fotorealismo
sfido chiunque a capire chi dei due
neymar
uno è un videogioco uno è una foto
però non deve coinvolgere solo la vista
deve coinvolgere tutti i sensi infatti
si stanno costruendo dei dispositivi
delle periferiche che unite creano una
totale immersione vita dell'esperienza
così da non far più scindere le due
parole ma crearne una sola realta
virtuale non è un pensiero che nasce
nell ultimo tempo nasce molto prima
sicuramente la fantascienza viene detto
sempre che anticipa nettamente la
scienza quindi già nell'ottocento
venivano teorizzate i primi concetti di
realtà virtuale un romanzo
dell'ottocento parla di un amore folle
di un ragazzo verso una donna parla con
l'amico genio e inventore questo ragazzo
cerca di risolvere comunque al sias
ingegnere problema risoluzione e gliela
crea mi crea il primo concetto di donna
virtuale poi gliela tramuta in hologram
e poi viene ricoperta da una sostanza
per creare la pelle quindi il solo in
questo libro ci sono tre concetti realtà
virtuale ologramma e cyborg
successivamente si teorizzano anche i
primi abbracci i primi abbracci a
distanza non a caso la settimana scorsa
su cessato il primo abbraccio virtuale
poi da ovviamente dalle idee si passa
dai prototipi è inevitabile e quindi i
primi prototipi ingombranti e vediamo il
senso rama oppure la spada di damocle
degli anni 70 il visore di mio nonno è
molto semplice 8 per poi arrivare al
virtual boy la feccia non non è a caso
vult decrescere la realtà virtuale
tant'è che negli anni 90 e
successivamente nel ii nel film il
tagliaerbe viene teorizzato anche il
declino o anche si pensa ad un nuovo
nuovo millennio pieno di realtà virtuale
è il nuovo millennio il nostro quindi
quasi un nostradamus però sta toccando
un punto che dirò fra poco
quello di utilizzare la realtà virtuale
in senso positivo all'inizio infatti il
ragazzo viene tra virgolette curato con
la realtà virtuale per poi avere una
paura la paura finale il controllo della
mente è vero come ogni cosa
l'uso el'abuso vediamo l'immagine
emblematica e chissà che visione chissà
cosa starà vedendo però in un angolo di
una stanza attaccata ad una presa in una
stanza fatiscente e malata quindi
dobbiamo anche capire come usare come
abusare della di una tecnologia come il
coltello può tagliare il pane può anche
uccidere
quindi anche la realtà virtuale come
qualsiasi tecnologia può avere un abuso
e all'uso l'uso videogiochi prima di
arrivare ai serious game
devo parlare dei videogiochi videogiochi
nascono proprio per intrattenerci per
divertirci serious game e nascono da
videogiochi però utilizzano quella
tecnologia per applicarle in contesti
diversi
appunto diversi serie e quindi nascono e
serious game è come è successo con i
videogiochi 2d 3d anche la realtà
virtuale sta vivendo questo periodo e ho
la fortuna e l'esperienza o questa
esperienza cioè applicare la realtà
virtuale in contenti si diversi
sicuramente contesti come la formazione
e l'educazione la psicologia la medicina
non a caso o sto avendo la fortuna di
seguire dai progetti in cui si applica
la realtà virtuale in uso medico
diagnosi del comportamento oppure
introdotti in sedute terapeutiche al
pari di un disco di appare di una
medicina quindi introdurre la realtà
virtuale e all'interno di cicli
terapeutici all'educazione senza dubbio
vivere un'esperienza te la far ricordare
meglio oppure il wellness e unire il
nostro movimento e magari e sfidare un
nostro amico in una pedalata in un
velodromo è perché becks servizi appunto
come ho detto poco fa serious game e
nascono in ambito medico all'ambito
medico l'utenza è diversa dal video
il videogioco anzi la complessità
stimola l'interesse delle persone perché
perché fa parte del gioco
nell'ambito sirius l'utenza e variegata
ed eterogenea quindi la semplicità è
d'obbligo e tant'è che se partiamo da di
sori 16 quello di mio nonno
andiamo ad una complessità la squadra di
laurea stiamo ritornando alla semplicità
dell'utilizzo così da poter far
utilizzare la tecnologia quanto meno
invasiva possibile quindi sì c'è si
cerca di far vivere un'esperienza quanto
più facile e semplice quindi con un
interazione uomo macchina pari a zero al
back to semplicity io subito dovuto
aggiungere una parola il back to umani
ti bellissimo bellissimo che è pensare
che due persone una milano una catania
oa anche dall'altra parte del mondo si
possono incontrare nella realtà virtuale
è bellissimo pensare che si possa agire
sulla mente umana per aiutarla
bellissimo però dobbiamo cercare di
tornare alla nostra umanità dobbiamo
cercare il 3d esasperato fotorealismo
tutto quello che vogliamo però non
dobbiamo dimenticarci della nostra tv
tridimensionalità umana fatta di carne
ed ossa
quindi se è bello prendere un caffè da
new york a catania con il visore con la
tuta per l'abbraccio con il dispositivo
che tifa l'olfatto cieli di cura l'ho
fatto e quindi di far sentire l'odore la
fragranza del caffè se il nostro amico e
di catania stessa prendete un insieme
grazie